[Music]
won't you help to
S these songs of freedom is all I
have Redemption
songs when you write
that all my
[Applause]
life
are you ready for Bob Marley and the
wi a h is the people
music you know you're a
superstar a
superstar you can't separate the music
and the message you see reg music com
for unify the people not Everyone likes
what you're saying for your own safety
you need to
[Music]
stop on December 3rd 1976 WBY assassins
invaded Bob Marley's home and attempted
to take the life of the singer wife and
don't worry about that don't
worry every little going to be all right
you like that one yeah
there's a war going on oh I can bring
peace I can't even get peace for myself
right up this
morning smile with the Rising Sun three
little
[Music]
bird
sometimes the messenger has to become
the
[Music]
message
Bob I know it's
dangerous but you're the only one who
can unite the
people you ready
B no guns can stop this
message all I want the World to
[Music]
Change and that time is
no
[Applause]
my message to
[Music]
you